[Music]
foreign
good God that disturbing cold open was
like secession on crack I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's June 21st
2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
locals and YouTube join us for the post
game show where you can add your Insight
and offer up your queries at
reubenreport.locals.com and do not
forget in case you missed it yesterday
we have launched the new Reuben report
store over at daverubin dot store we've
got the make America Florida shirt the
LGBT t-shirt but it means some other
stuff we've got a couple Reuben reports
shared some other fun things there's
mugs there's hoodies sweatshirts all
sorts of stuff uh I want to start off
the show today with something very very
important because when we woke up this
morning we thought we were going to be
dead
check this out five years ago
Greta thunberg a top climate scientist
is warning that climate change will wipe
out all of humanity unless we stop using
fossil fuels over the next five years
she sent that in June 21st 2018 five
years ago
I woke up here I am are you guys here
everybody's here everyone's okay
thank you for waving to me we made it
people I'm starting to think that the
climate thing is just a giant hoax and
uh a grift what do you think you think I
might be right but that's not what we're
talking about today we're talking about
other hoaxes and griffs involving Hunter
Biden Joe Biden Donald Trump and the
rest of it uh yes we covered it a little
bit yesterday just for a moment or two
because it broke right before we went
live uh Hunter Biden
has copped a plea deal on a couple of
these charges but we are now going to
take you through the entire thing the
entire way the media has lied about him
Joe Biden their relationship to this
Ukrainian Energy company the payoffs the
money the media the just the whole orgy
of insanity and how it relates to
Endless Lies what I have had just about
enough with are the Endless Lies I can
deal with some lies I can deal with some
nonsense some BS I cannot deal with an
endless Deluge of Endless Lies like
we're a duck being force-fed you know
how they make pate they force feed the
duck and they just dump feed that's what
they are doing to us with lies and by
the way the lies are coming obviously
always from the left and from CNN and
Washington Post the New York Times but
now they're also coming from Donald
Trump they're coming from all over the
place and if you're saying it's going to
get harder to be sane but you're not the
only one and that's what we're devoting
the show to today truth people it's out
there let's find it before we do any of
that let me talk to you guys about ramp
you know do you feel like your finance
software isn't cutting it do you want
the lead latest and greatest in
financial software to simply spend help
you save time and keep you from getting
trapped in busy work check out ramp ramp
is the corporate card and expense
management software designed to help you
save time and put money back in your
pocket ramp gives Finance teams
unprecedented control and insight into
company spend with ramp you're able to
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
like for example when Conor buys extra
guacamole without permission I now am
alerted ramps accounting software
automatically collects and your receipts
and categorizes your expenses in real
time so you don't have to you never have
to chase down a receipt again and your
employees will no longer spend hours
submitting expense reports the next time
you uh the time you'll save each month
on employee expenses will allow you to
close your books eight times faster ramp
saves you money businesses that use ramp
save an average of 3.5 percent in the
first year and now get 250 when you join
ramp just go to ramp.com Ruben that's
ramp.com slash Reuben and now back to me
we also have the Reuben report mug at
daverubin dot store all right Tucker
Carlson have you heard of this guy
number one host in the history of cable
news millions and millions and millions
of viewers every night culturally
relevant making sense to an awful lot of
people was once on Fox news then out of
nowhere is no longer on Fox News he has
relaunched I would say a streamlined
version of his show much more sort of in
line with what we do here which does not
surprise me because Tucker as you guys
know a couple years ago walked into my
garage in Sherman Oaks California and
said holy F and you're doing it
right Dave he has now created his own
version of this he is free he's doing
the show on the Twitter right now and he
covered a bit about this Hunter Biden uh
well let's just say hunter got off easy
perhaps almost scot-free by the justice
department here's Tucker
this morning Hunter Biden pleaded guilty
to pretty much nothing Biden pled to two
misdemeanor tax evasion charges then
entered a diversion on a federal gun
charge that's it as far as Merrick
Garland's justice department is
concerned Hunter Biden is done
there was no pre-dawn raid carried live
simultaneously on CNN there was no perp
walk no handcuffs no press conference
above all there was no felony
Hunter Biden who broke federal gun laws
can still carry a gun
it's like it all never happened in fact
the justice department just baptized
Hunter Biden a lifetime of sins washed
away in an instant it was a secular
mirror okay so we'll get a little bit
more into the charges in a second and uh
Tucker's also going to talk a bit more
about what they ignored but in essence
they're getting him on a bunch of
nothing and they're not really getting
him because it's already been played
away he's not going to be in jail these
are federal gun charges misdemeanor
charges and they're all just going away
and now one of the things that we're
constantly talking about here especially
as it relates to Trump is the asymmetry
of the law right most people just want
equal well they want equal protection
under the law but they also want equal
application of the law so the Department
of Justice should go after people
equally regardless of their political
beliefs regardless of whether they're a
democrat or republican or anything else
so we know obviously the case in New
York uh after Trump now there's the the
federal case there's going to be another
case in Georgia like they're throwing
everything they got at Trump right and
it seems very very asymmetrical when you
look at the fact that when it comes to
classified documents vice president then
at the time Joe Biden has classified
documents Mike Pence classified
documents Hillary bleach bit all the
stuff so here a lot of people when they
saw the charges immediately this is what
I noticed yesterday for the first hour
everybody was like all right finally we
got some symmetry they're going after a
Democrat it's very exciting because you
know the headline comes out it's like
Department of Justice is gonna you know
indict or come up with a deal with uh
with Hunter Biden so there's this moment
of like oh they're doing something but
then five minutes later basically as
more information comes out you see that
it's not much of anything and that it's
not getting to the real issues around
Hunter Biden like why did a crackhead
with no experience get paid eighty
thousand dollars a month to work at a
Ukrainian Energy company while his dad
was vice president I don't know a lot of
Ukrainian energy companies that are
hiring crackheads and I know plenty of
Ukrainian energy companies I'm out there
anyway Tucker had a little bit more on
that a sad family tragedy that's the
framing and then this a sentence
choreographed to the letter your son
while there's no ties to you could be
charged by your Department of Justice
got that
while there's no tie to you so the
answer is in fact in the question
whatever Hunter Biden goes down for and
we know he is going to be George because
MSNBC said so but when that happens
that's Hunter's problem it's got nothing
to do with Joe Biden rest easy America
so you get what's going on here Hunter
Biden only had the job at a Ukrainian
Energy company because of his father
Hunter Biden also became worth millions
and millions of dollars did that happen
why did he get these jobs who's the big
man why did Biden who's been a you know
a civil servant in essence for now he's
been in government for I think 49 years
40 freaking nine years uh I'm only 40.
I'll be 47 in four days the guy's been
in public office for 49 years how did he
become a millionaire throughout all of
this anyway the daily wires got a bit
more on the specifics of what he was
actually pleading guilty to Hunter Biden
will plead guilty to two tax crimes and
admit the facts of a gun charge in a
plea deal with Federal prosecutors
according to a new report The Washington
Post reported Tuesday that Hunter who
has been facing a multi-year
investigation by officials negotiated a
deal with Delaware U.S attorney David
Weiss how convenient Delaware U.S
attorney where was Joe Biden a senator
Hunter will plead guilty to failing to
pay about a hundred thousand in taxes
for 2017 and for failing to pay a
similar amount for 2018 the tax charges
Hunter face are misdemeanors he is
expected not to face any jail time and
to be given two years of probation the
53 year old will also reportedly enter a
diversion program upon admitting the
illegal purchase of a firearm in 2018.
the gun charge could be revoked from his
record upon completion of the diversion
program according to sources who spoke
to the post previous reports had
indicated that Hunter Biden's tax
liability was paid for by high-powered
Hollywood Attorney Kevin Morris Morris
reportedly foot the bill for over 2
million of Biden's taxes and worked with
him on his art career the plea deal was
criticized by conservatives who argue
Hunter Biden was getting a special
treatment because he's the president's
son Brett Tolman the former U.S attorney
for Utah also decried the deal saying
they are ignoring Decades of policy and
precedent to seek felonies not
misdemeanors and seek Sen sentences
within the guideline range the diversion
agreement on the felony is offensive to
anyone not politically connected who
sought diversions and were literally
laughed at by the doj the reported deal
comes as Hunter and his father President
Joe Biden have been facing inquiries
from Republican lawmakers over an
alleged 5 million
dollar bribery bribery is giving Robin
Ukraine okay guys there's a couple
things here he had no qualifications to
get this job at barisma so you know like
we just know this
that there was a reason that they hired
him and it was only because his dad was
vice president at the time that's that's
one thing the other thing that he had
millions and millions of dollars that
this lawyer helped him with two million
dollars in taxes think how much if
you're paying two million dollars in
taxes think how much money you're
actually making as an artist art you
know the art world it's a giant money
laundering scheme what you can do is
since you can't just give someone
millions and millions of dollars just
like that right you can't do it you
don't want things on the record on the
books and everything else but you can
buy art at crazy inflated prices art is
of course completely subjective so you
could have a crackhead dribbling out
some nonsense with uh with a pen and you
could be like oh my God I will buy that
uh Hunter Biden original for three
million dollars the whole thing I mean
the whole everyone knows this the whole
art world is in absolute farce but okay
I get it you get it right we all get it
that there's an asymmetry in the law and
instead of getting Hunter on any of the
important things here they're are
basically getting him on some nonsense
by the way you know who should be really
freaking pissed today can you Google
this one for me remember Wesley Snipes
actor Wesley Snipes white men don't jump
can't jump well they don't jump they
can't jump whatever how many years did
he spend in prison because of tax
evasion I think he had a he had like a
2.5 million dollar situation and and he
was in jail for like two years if I'm
not mistaken basically the same thing so
I suppose he was in jail for three years
for three years Wesley Snipes did anyone
think Wesley Snipes was a criminal and I
actually I agree I I remember when it
happened I had sympathy with him because
you know when you're a big actor and
you've got all these people working for
you don't you're not in charge of paying
your own taxes you hope you've hired
somebody to do some of it it's not that
he has no blame like at the end the Buck
has to stop with someone but the point
is they'll they'll put a black
millionaire in jail for this exact same
thing but if you're the president's son
white privilege and all that stuff I
guess you get off the hook but let's
talk about the media because the media
of course first now is carrying water
for Hunter Biden and we will show you
that they have been doing this for quite
some time here is the most unlikable oh
can we put the uh let's put it up over
there here we go we got it yeah there
you go uh we've got the uh most
unlikable person on all of television
and that is not easy this is Sunny
Hostin of the view uh who's a lawyer
I've told she's a lawyer and she's she
feels very confident in what happened
here
applicants we'll call them a slap on the
wrist but the but hunter Biden now has a
criminal record yeah and that's what
they wanted right well and it shows that
no one is above the law which is
important not even the president's son
let me ask you this um Jonathan because
this investigation began in 2018. I
remember in 2014 you asking questions
about Hunter Biden and barisma and what
was going on with that and was that
nepotism why are we only seeing charges
five years later and why are these
charges limited to these these cases so
do you see how the machine operates she
can get up there with a straight face
say no one's against the law because
they're slapping his wrists with
something they're not putting him in
jail for something other people Wesley
Snipes for example would be in jail for
right they cop the plea deal before they
even released any of the information but
then it allows her to go see no one's
Above the Law even the president's son
because it's all a grift and an endless
lie and the problem for these people is
more of us are seeing it every freaking
day by the way that guy Jonathan Carl
there I have nothing against him
personally but when don't burn this book
my first book came out we sold like 30
000 copies in the first week New York
Times put us at number 11. we should
have been number two his book and you
see sales numbers I mean the new
literally they fudge sales numbers his
book sold about 4 000 copies and I think
they put him at number four because if
you're in the machine and you do the
bidding of the machine they'll help you
and if you don't they won't anyway
that's a little sidebar but let's
continue CNN is also defending the
Department of Justice uh because you
know CNN's in on the thing
obviously you're already hearing a lot
of shouting oh sweetheart deal oh this
oh that none of us really knows the
details of the possible charges here and
exactly what was agreed to as part of
this plea Jennifer but how do how does
one assess whether this is the type of
deal that a normal person not a
President's child would get in this
circumstance so you would look to other
similar cases right so on the gun form
charge it's very very standard for
someone in this situation who lies on
the form because they're an addict I
mean that clown what's his name Berman I
think his name's Berman we don't know
the details as CNN behind him on a giant
screen is bulleting out the details what
the hell is wrong with you people
of course he is getting a sweetheart
deal again Ask Wesley Snipes ask all of
the thousands I'm gonna guess there's
probably hundreds of thousands of people
I don't even know if you can find out
this number can you find out how many
people are in jail right now for federal
tax evasion let's see if we can even
find that number I'm gonna guess there's
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands but again that's a moot point
because that's not what really they know
that's not really what this is about
they want you to think this is about one
gun charge and a little bit of tax
evasion when it's really about whatever
crazy stuff he and his dad were doing
when his dad was VP and he was
influencing these Ukrainian energy
companies and by the way I don't know if
you guys know about this but we're in
this war not war right now with Ukraine
do you think that's uh possibly
connected how many people 370 that's it
wow I'm actually shocked according to
Phoenix we're doing this on the Fly
there are only 370 people in jail on
federal tax evasion right now
all right interesting uh video here we
go uh this is John heilman you'll
remember John Holloman we got a
throwback on him in just a second uh
who's he saying are the stupid people
right now well of course it's
Republicans
can't be said enough times when you
listen to people like Captain McCarthy
and others talking about the the
two-tier system of justice and the
double standard you just want to you
just want to say double standard yeah
here's this here's this Trump appointed
uh prosecutor who was kept in office by
Joe Biden something that that Donald
Trump would never have done in the
similar circumstance can you imagine can
you imagine an Obama appointed
prosecutor looking into one of the Trump
kids when if Trump won the presidency
and Trump say you know what uh for both
a matters of both substance and
perception I'm going to leave this Obama
appointed prosecutor in uh to look at
Don Jr uh because I just want to make
sure that everyone has full faith uh in
the legal system and not being
politicized it's it's that like a
hallucinatory fantasy that could ever
happen and yet that's what Joe Biden did
and now all of these same Republicans
who want to uh take this subject we want
to figure out some way to Pivot away
from Donald Trump's legal woes uh they
focus on this and say oh my God two tier
standard of Justice he got a sweetheart
deal and you're like guys I mean you're
just you just sound like morons when you
say these things you could say a lot of
things about this but not that
say that again and this is exactly why
they did it the way that they did it you
get him on a bunch of nothing that he
doesn't pay the price for and someone
else pays the bill on right and then you
ignore what the real problem is and then
you get these clowns like John heilman
to go out on MSNBC and say oh my God
this is really about Trump's legal woes
uh you might remember John heilman
remember this one this is from about two
months ago this one caught fire absolute
fire on the internet and then caused
John heilman to block me on Twitter uh
this is Russell Brand demolishing John
heilman on Real Time with Bill Maher
I've not known you long but I love you
already but I have to say that it's it's
disingenuous to claim that the biases
they're exhibited on Fox News are any
different from the biases exhibit on
MSNBC it's difficult to suggest but
these corporations operate as anything
other than mouthpieces for their
affiliate owners in BlackRock and
Vanguard and unless we start to embrace
and also mate like just spiritually if I
may use that word in your great country
we have to take responsibility for our
own perspective I've been on that MSNBC
mate it was propagandist nut crackery
Good morning Joe it was absurd The Way
They Carried Good morning Joe yes
it wasn't morning there's no one called
Joe there no one could concentrate they
didn't understand the basic tennis of
Journalism no one was willing to stick
up for genuine American Heroes uh like
Edward Snowden no one was willing to
talk about Julian Assange and what he's
suffered trying to bring real journalism
to the American people and I think to
see it within the castle of MSNBC
throwing rocks at Fox News is ludicrous
make MSNBC better make them SMBC great
again my friend I would love it wasn't
morning there was no one named Joe there
just absolutely perfect anyway what he's
doing of course is just he's just
pulling the curtain back and going
you're all freaking frauds but as long
as we're on the fraud train here's
another one from the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC a guy named
Andrew Weitzman and of course it's not a
sweetheart deal
bird that this is not some sweetheart
deal but this is pretty standard my own
experience is that first time tax
defenses like this are generally treated
pretty leniently as well as the
um the felony count which is the
pre-trial diversion there's substantial
issues that that statute may be
unconstitutional so I think that all in
all this seems like a very fair
resolution
again they are not telling you what the
real issue is they're also lying about
that they don't really go after people
for this Wesley Snipes I've got Phoenix
doing a little more work on the Wesley
Snipes case we'll have more on that in
just a second let's continue with MSNBC
here's a guy I love this guy's name I
don't think he's that bright don't
particularly like the guy but I love the
name this is Frank bigaluzzi okay he
definitely was in season three of The
Sopranos as an extra uh saying that this
was a rare charge and the prosecutor
really went out of his way to even make
anything happen here
so Frank in addition to these tax
charges uh Hunter Biden faced a separate
gun charge but that will go to a
pre-trial diversion agreement and will
not be subject to the plea agreement can
you explain what that means
yeah the heart of that charge Jose is
really the fact that Hunter did not
disclose that he was a drug addict when
he came to apply for and and obtain the
gun it's a rare charge because it's so
difficult to prove that someone is a
drug addict at a specific point in time
so because that's the core of the charge
the diversion is often to ensure that
you're drug free moving forward so what
we'll see here is an agreement that I
will remain clean from drugs for the
next 24 months and that's likely to
involve testing
um it's again a rare charge I think it
it indicates that the prosecutor has
gone out of his way
to charge everything that could have
been charged and then with regard to the
the tax charges it's been my experience
in FBI cases that have adjacent tax
violations the IRS is not so much when
it comes to individuals not so much
interested in punishment but rather
getting the overdue funds back and in
this case it appears Hunter has paid
over a million dollars back and that's I
think why in part we're seeing
misdemeanor charges only
okay where did he get the millions and
millions of dollars in the first place
that he was avoiding taxes on right
that's the number one issue the man was
a talentless crack addict so you might
want to go oh you know he owes all these
millions of dollars in taxes his dad was
the vice president he had this weird job
do you think that there's something
going on there do you think that that
might actually be the real issue not the
rest of this by the way little more on
Wesley Snipes he went to jail for three
years it was his first time avoiding
federal tax uh federal tax authorities
2010 he went to jail for three years so
this is not so freaking rare now here's
the best one of all of them this is
MSNBC contributor Claire mccaskill
former she was former senator from where
where's she from again Claire mccaskill
where was she from like Idaho or where
was she from
I don't want to blame the good people
who live there Missouri
a fine State the great state of Missouri
they they she's no longer the senator uh
here she is she's an MSNBC contributor
telling everybody just get off Joe's
back leave Joe alone
cynical bad that nobody nobody views
this as a normal family nobody knows
that the bidens have dealt with loss and
pain what do you make of the fact that
David Jolly's point that they should
take this loss and move on find another
political weapon to wield
so what America they live in
um and I don't know how they sleep at
night
you know alcoholism and addiction are
probably the most pervasive diseases in
America I don't know of one family
that hasn't been touched
by the pain
of these diseases
and it's particularly painful when you
have someone you love unconditionally
that is suffering from these diseases
and by the way everybody needs to back
off Joe Biden about this he loves his
son back off it is okay for him to love
his son and there's nothing wrong with
it they have no evidence of any kind of
wrongdoing by Joe Biden and it
infuriates me that they're using this
heartbreak against Joe Biden in this way
it's just not right she is a perfect
leftist she's a perfect leftist nothing
she said there has anything to do with
the law everything she said there had to
do with pulling heartstrings but really
pulling them sort of in the wrong
direction right like no one's saying
that Joe Biden can't love his son no
one's saying don't have sympathy for
people that are hooked on alcohol and
drugs right we all know somebody that's
been affected by alcohol and drugs we've
all had our our own struggles whatever
it might be nobody's saying any of that
the issue here first off what they got
him on was tax evasion but the issues
all the other stuff that I've now
repeated Ad nauseam for the 20 minutes
or so that we've been doing this
the idea that this has nothing to do
with Joe Biden that's what she
repeatedly is saying there this has
nothing to do with Joe Biden lady Claire
mccaskill I tweeted this at you
yesterday so now I will repeat it on
video and people can cut it and send it
to you Claire mccaskill who was vice
president when crackhead Hunter Biden
got a job for eighty thousand dollars a
year at a Ukrainian Energy company with
no qualifications
his name is Joe Biden he's the president
now do you think that a Ukrainian Energy
company might want to give a job to a
guy who might have access to the vice
president so that they could get some
sort of deal pulled off does that seem
too crazy to you or am I just being mean
you tell me
anywho uh let's do a couple Super Cuts
here here is a super cut video of
mainstream media reporting on the hunter
bike
there's no evidence that Hunter Biden
has done anything wrong there is no
evidence of any wrongdoing between uh by
Biden by Joe Biden or by Hunter Biden
there's no evidence that Joe Biden
actually did anything wrong or did
anything to sway things in Hunter
Biden's favor he's denied that his son
ever lobbied him for anything there is
nothing Hunter there is nothing wrong
that Vice President Biden did President
Trump has falsely
accused your son of doing something
wrong while serving in a company board
in Ukraine I want to point out there's
no evidence of wrongdoing by either one
of you there is no evidence that anybody
did anything illegal uh regarding the
bidens uh and and Ukraine and and Joe
Biden was carrying out U.S policy
president Trump wanted dirt on Joe and
Hunter Biden Trump's claims about
wrongdoing here are unsubstantiated we
have looked lots of out outlets have
looked Hunter Biden did nothing wrong
Vice President Biden did nothing wrong
at every single media outlet has said
that there are no there's no there there
to these allegations lies and smears
politifacts found no evidence to support
the idea that Joe Biden advocated with
his son's interests in mind it's true
that there's no evidence of any
wrongdoing by Vice President Biden or
that Hunter Biden uh broke any laws at
all what it confirms is that Hunter
Biden is a person of Integrity Hunter
has done nothing wrong I've never a
memoir like this one before this is
Hunter Biden's book beautiful things
it's breathtaking
we should have just ended the show right
there I actually should have just walked
offset and just ended for the day like
how could I beat that unbelievable okay
but you get it they just carry water for
them we know if it was the reverse let's
not forget what was it back in
gosh what it was it it was maybe the
fall of 2020 or something when Donald
who came out that Donald Trump Jr had
had lunch for 10 minutes with a Russian
on the Upper East Side and people went
completely insane this proves that
Donald Trump was coordinating with the
Russians to steal the election that was
back when you could say that an election
was stolen
you get all of it now uh let's show you
another super cut gotta go to the second
Supercut it's a rare back-to-back Super
cut day over here at the Reuben report
here is the mainstream media reporting
that the hunter Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation which of course turned
out to be completely untrue
go ahead
no no I probably best I don't
obviously uh we're not going with the
New York Post story uh right now on
Hunter Biden this is really one of the
stupidest October surprises I've ever
seen it helps to really view this as
storytelling not so much as news
coverage but as political entertainment
NPR explained we don't want to waste our
time on stories that are not really
stories who even thought to make that
story up it's a story that many
intelligence experts say has all the
Hallmarks of a foreign interference
campaign it looks like it's tied to
Vladimir Putin in Moscow this is a
Russian intelligence disinformation
campaign foreign intelligence operation
foreign intelligence operation Russian
intelligence Rudy Giuliani was not fed
passively Russian disinformation he
ordered off the menu this is a classic
example of the right wing media machine
and he's an image of a scandal he's not
and he's taking of course he is honestly
we should note Hunter Biden isn't
running for president that argument has
been debunked there is no evidence that
Joe Biden did anything wrong for all we
know these emails are made up it just
lacks credibility okay
and start doing that verification no
we're not going to do your work for you
Character Matters it matters tell them
the truth matters
being a good person matters
they're making my job very easy here's
more uh you remember this guy this like
when you talk about like sort of like
just like the worst of the worst of the
just deep State soulless nothing people
this is former Obama CIA director James
Clapper now you may remember James
Clapper from about what about eight nine
years ago or so he is the one that was
testifying to Congress he lied to
Congress and of course you know you can
always get away in line with Congress
they asked him if uh you know if our
intelligence services are spying against
Americans and he scratched his head
remember you know in Seinfeld when
you're lying you touch your face and the
higher up on your face that you touch
means the bigger the LIE he remember
he's scratching his head going not
wittingly not wittingly that's what he
said so he fully lied to Congress then
he is one of the people uh that labeled
uh the Biden laptop as Russian
disinformation we know that about what
was it 51 former intelligence officials
uh said the same thing it all everyone
that you heard there in the media lied
right and then our intelligence
officials all Allied here's James
Clapper with CNN's Caitlin Collins and
this is after we already found out that
it was real but he still has no regrets
this freaking guy
well
well let me ask you a question no I I
don't regret it I uh I thought at the
time that was appropriate to sound a
warning about watch out for the dark
hand of the Russians and in my case this
is uh on the heels of what I saw the
Russians do in 2016 to interfere and
influence the outcome of our election so
I thought it was appropriate I thought
the letter was appropriately caveat by
acknowledging we didn't have any direct
evidence and to this day I still have
not seen any official
results of a forensic analysis of that
laptop as to whether or not in some way
the Russians uh mess with it incredible
incredible still that's from yesterday
the guy is still now saying oh we didn't
even have a forensic analysis so I don't
even know what the freak I was talking
about oh and by the way yeah you're
allowed to talk about election
interference from 2016. these people are
such they're just so lucky that so many
Americans are stupid
that really was the plan make everyone
stupid through you know a couple decades
of brainless nonsensical public
education make everyone stupid and then
there'll be a few people left
you guys watching this going is anyone
paying attention is anyone anyone are
the lights on here anyone anyone one
more super cut for you here is the
elderly man pretending to be President
Joe Biden who got his son the job at
barisma do not pretend that he didn't if
he didn't have the job as VP his son
would have been smoking the parmesan
cheese out of the carpet and all that
stuff he would not have had the gig here
he is insisting that his son is innocent
of old charges
God
my son did nothing wrong
I did nothing wrong and it turns out he
did not do a single thing wrong as
everybody's investigated so these guys
are amazing so you think that everything
that happened was kosher you know
there's not one single bit of evidence
not one little tiny bit to this anything
done was wrong
you know that but you keep asking me
these questions it's okay so last this
effort and this desperate campaign to
smear me and my family the vast majority
of the intelligence people have come out
and said there's no basis at all this is
classic Trump
we have four days left and all of a
sudden there's a laptop there's
overwhelming evidence that from the
intelligence community that the Russians
are engaged say what he's saying is a
bunch of garbage he's a grown man he is
the smartest man I know I mean I'm
afraid of pure intellectual capacity how
will that impact your presidency
first of all my son's done nothing wrong
I trust him I have faith in him and it
impacts my presidency by making me feel
proud of you you know one thing we
didn't show you there remember that
quote we've shown it in the past where
Joe Biden he basically is some something
to the effect of uh we've never
discussed business remember that we've
never even discussed Hunter and I have
never discussed business
like imagine believing that really do
you know what your son does for a living
besides smoking crack like do you have
any sense is there anything there uh
also this thing about not one bit of
evidence the evidence is that he had a
job he wasn't quite you know what Daphne
can you do me a favor can you get my
resume together I haven't looked for a
job in a while I've been doing this
thing whatever I'm doing here can you
put my resume together and I want you to
submit it to all the Ukrainian energy
companies out there and let's see if I
get any calls back okay
my dad was in the Garment Center he's
retired I don't know that he's been able
to pull any strings we'll see what
happens anyway okay all day long we
could do the left lies the media lives
Biden lies we can do all that and I know
you guys get it and I think it's
important to you know Shine the Light on
every now and again and all that stuff
but we have another problem on the
horizon because because Trump you know
he had this interview with Brett Baer
the other day and he just lied and lied
and lied and lied and then his social
media team the Trump war room and the
rest of them started lying and lying and
lying and lying and I think for all of
us decent people we are now caught
between two really powerful
um what we call them like really
powerful movements that are based in
lies and it's going to make it harder to
tell the truth but I also think they
think it makes it more worthy to tell
the truth so uh let's just move forward
a little bit uh Phoenix girl for me
would you uh what do we have next uh oh
here is okay so here's one of the lies
that they released after the Brett Bear
interview they the Trump War Room team
put this out on Twitter it already got
fact checked and everything else it also
got ratioed to high hell they called uh
Ron DeSantis lockdown Ron and they put
out this two minute video we're gonna
only show you about 30 seconds here of
uh of how DeSantis in Florida were the
worst when it came to coffee
Governor Ron DeSantis shut down Florida
businesses during covid drove away
tourism and used to mandate to keep
Floridians from leaving their homes
issues a wide reaching Mandate of
parties over in Florida he wants you to
forget but Floridians remember we can't
stand another three months being shut
down please Governor open us up it
actually shut us down it just made no
sense we did it for for the bars and
closed the bars down lockdown run he
failed Florida don't let him fail
America
lockdown run it's so effing embarrassing
and dishonest everyone locked down at
the beginning federally and statewise
everyone did the difference was that
DeSantis very quickly and we're going to
show you some dates in just a second to
say it just very very quickly realized
it was not working the science did not
make sense he did not want people to not
be with their loved ones as they were
dying he did not want to stop people
from going to work and all of those
other things Trump as he walked out of
the White House years after kovid gave
fauci an award okay so the idea that
he's calling him lockdown run I moved
you guys all know my journey but but
think about the dates on this I arrived
in Florida in December of 21. coven
started you know basically like February
of 2020. so a year and a half later I
arrived in Florida because in California
we still had Mass mandates you had to
have vaccine passports they were going
to force my guys to be vaccinated to
work for me and everything else and I
arrived to the place that was the beacon
of freedom and still remains that so
he's it's so Twisted what Trump is doing
because make an argument for Trump but
all he can do is lie all he can do is
lie uh here is uh Chris Cuomo no longer
with CNN but this is back in December of
2020 uh Trump calling for Florida to
lock down because yeah Ron DeSantis had
opened up
uh the Orlando Sentinel quotes the task
force insisting Florida must
re-establish strong mitigation Statewide
and efforts should continue to include
wearing masks in public avoiding or
eliminating the opportunities for
massless crowding in public including
bars but bars are open in Florida and
DeSantis went out of his way to weaken
mask rules can you believe that the
santis went out of his way to make sure
you could wear what you want and if you
wanted to go to work you could go to
work and try to get kids back to school
and everything else now the real issue
here though because look nobody is clean
nobody is clean I was Bamboozled by 15
days to stop spreading all of those
things and then some we all woke up to
different degrees the issue is the
people that woke up earlier deserve some
credit for it and we shouldn't just
rewrite history in front of our faces
Florida has become the beacon to the
world of what Freedom means right it
really has so Trump did this interview
with Brett Bear and you the interesting
thing that Trump is having to deal with
right now is Trump seems to have no
regrets over operation warp speed
getting the vaxes in all the arms and
and everything else despite the fact
that the base hates the vaccine hate
hates warp speed heaps hates big Pharma
and all of the rest of it but the real
issue is that I think all Trump has to
do but he this is what he's incapable of
doing all Trump has to do is be like you
know what I did actually get bamboozled
by fauci and some of these guys and
Berks and whatever and maybe we did push
warp speed too much and I listened to
too many people that were connected to
Big Pharma and too many people NIH and
CDC and everything else and I do have
some regrets that's all he has to do but
watch this not only does he have no
regrets he says no watch this but then
uh let's contrast that this is one video
right one video so watch Trump at the
beginning
he's still in June of 2023 saying he has
no regrets now and then watch the second
half is August 2020 Ron DeSantis
regrets about how you handled that
because some of your opponents are
because some of your opponents are but
we will never do any of these lockdowns
um again and I hear people say they'll
shut down the country and honestly I
cringe because you know we know places
that have done that the most Draconian
lockdown in the world has been Peru
military and force since March they have
the highest per capita mortality in the
world from covid and at best what a
lockdown will do is delay it does not
reduce the ultimate uh mortality okay
again I know a whole bunch of you were
frustrated with me yesterday because I
went hard on Trump but you have to tell
me how this makes sense to you not just
I'm going to vote for Trump no about it
no matter what Trump is a superhero from
a Marvel movie and everyone else is evil
and blah blah blah blah blah give me the
honest answer what's the honest answer
there two days ago Trump is saying he
still has no regrets
right and there you have August of 2020.
DeSantis was waking up he was opening up
the state he was even doing it earlier
than that right that's three years ago
and and this and Trump is still saying
No Regrets here's I mean this is easy
stuff but here's Trump repeatedly
praising DeSantis because he loved
DeSantis before DeSantis decided to run
for president uh he lives in Florida all
of his kids live in Florida all of his
grandkids live in Florida several of
them moved here during covid because of
DeSantis because Florida is open and
free
we're in a place called Florida and we
have a great Governor Ron DeSantis has
done a uh a spectacular job in Florida
terrific job he just announced that the
schools will be open in the fall enjoys
very high popularity and that's for a
reason the reason is he's doing a good
job and you're open and you're open and
you didn't close and you didn't close
and you're it's just amazing right it's
great a lot of people agree with what
he's done you guys aren't even open yet
what the hell is going on with your
state
you know Florida's open Florida's open
Florida is open Governor Ron DeSantis
doing a fantastic job if you look at
Florida if you look at South Carolina if
you look at so many different places
that have opened up I don't want to name
all of them but the ones that are most
energetic about opening they are doing
tremendous business Ron DeSantis of
Florida the governor doing a fantastic
job in Florida great governor knows
exactly what he's doing look at what's
going on in Florida it's incredible the
job the governor of Florida has done
it's incredible
the numbers they're doing the governor
like Ron DeSantis of Florida is doing a
great job
then yesterday he's putting out videos
lockdown Ron so all I'm I'm genuinely
putting this out there as a question for
those of you who are still supporting
Trump
are you okay with endless lying and
rewriting of Truth you might think Trump
is the best guy to defeat the Deep State
and that DeSantis won't scale sort of
federally or whatever but are you okay
with saying reality does not matter and
if you are then then I think people
should just say it I I would love if the
people that are always yelling at me on
Twitter would be like you know what I've
decided reality doesn't matter and
that's what my policy is and that's why
I'm voting for the guy uh here is a
little bit more from the Brett Bear
interview because Trump is going to
start having trouble with the base when
it comes to vaccines and I think he
kinds of he kind of knows it take a look
but you have a lot of people that love
the vaccines I mean you do they happen
to be more Democrat than they are
Republicans can I ask the question if
you have a lot of people there are
people that say I saved 100 Million
Lives I don't even talk about it
there are people that say I saved 100
million lives do you know that there are
people that say that Dave Rubin is the
most handsome man on Earth
that Dave Rubin is the most one there I
heard there are people that say that
Dave Rubin is the best human being to
ever live on the planet
you might want to tell other people that
he's completely making that up do we
know anybody did you Google it how many
people have said that Donald Trump saved
100 million lives and it's not even that
it's not even that the vaccines didn't
work and now there's vaccine injuries
and everything else we now know it
didn't stop covid you could still
transmit covid just like all of a sudden
but he just says there are people who
say
okay there are people who say uh you may
remember this one this is from about a
month ago Trump who doesn't seem to be
campaigning anymore right he's not he's
playing golf mostly these days and then
showing up to court every now and again
he was in Iowa I think about five or six
weeks ago and this was an interesting
moment because here is a constituent a
former Trump voter saying they're not
happy with him because of the vaccine
yeah
well you know everybody wanted a vaccine
at that time and I was able to do
something that nobody else could have
done getting it done very very rapidly
but I never was for mandates I was I
thought the mandates were terrible
and
and you know there's a big portion of
the country that thinks that was a great
thing you understand that not a lot of
the people in this room but there's a
big but there is a big portion look I
will give credit where credit is due he
was never for mandates I never once
heard Donald Trump that you should get
fired from your job if you don't take it
or the federal government should do it
or anything else that's fully on the
administration 100 without question the
the second answer there though you know
there's a lot of people who like it like
that's kind of irrelevant was it the
right thing to do or not I know everyone
was Bamboozled by this again everyone
was in over their head and I can only
imagine what it would be like to be the
president of the United States all of
the experts who now we know we shouldn't
be trusting as much but all of the
experts coming in going you better shut
down the country you better do all of
this we better do blah blah blah or
everyone's gonna die and it's like
Trump's like you know I used to build
casinos like I guess I have to listen to
you guys so I don't blame him in a
certain sense for all that what I blame
him now for is how about just have a
nice Maya culpa just have a moment of
humility is that completely is there
literally nothing in you that would
allow for that and be like boy to my own
base I'm sorry that I did that or I
guess in retrospect it wasn't the best
thing or I do have some regrets but he
seems to be unable to show even the
slightest bit of Contrition and I think
that is a problem uh there was one other
issue on the uh the prep era interview
that I wanted to show you uh because uh
there was this new uh crime bill that uh
Trump is pushing now and Brett got him
caught up in something I'll explain a
little bit more on the other side
as an example
a woman who you know very well
was in jail she had 24 more years to
serve she served for 22 years she had
Thomas Johnson Alice she was in the
Super Bowl high quality oh yeah
I said how many is and she was on a
telephone call and they were involved in
selling marijuana mostly marijuana
and she got like 50 years in jail but
she'd be killed under your plan
huh as a drug dealer no no no under my
oh under that uh it would depend on the
severity it would depend on the sad and
she's technically a former drug dealer
she the she had multi-million dollar
cocaine ring and a drug dealer look so
even Alice Johnson in that ad she can't
do it okay by the way if that was there
no she wouldn't be killed it would start
as of now so you wouldn't go to the Head
yes you're not going to retroactively
kill Alice Johnson now but the point is
the criminal Bill Criminal Justice
Reform Bill he's pushing now would have
this woman killed she was a not only
marijuana by the way she was a cocaine
dealer okay fine
I can put him aside what anyone thinks
about drugs and crack and all the rest
of it but he's touting this bill that
would have killed the very that he wants
the bill now
would have killed the very woman I met
Alice Johnson actually at the Trump
Hotel in DC two or three days later
after she was led out of jail she was
with a whole bunch of her friends I was
having dinner with uh with Candace
Candace Owens and Clay Travis and we
went up to them and we chatted and she
was a lovely woman sure she saw the
little cocaine okay nobody's perfect but
the point is Trump's new bill would have
her kill and he didn't even know that
like when he's like uh well well
guys the reason I'm trying to do all
this is not to relentlessly hit Trump I
I don't find it fun I I actually don't
find it fun like sometimes it's kind of
silly and he makes it sort of easy with
with the nonsense
um but we have to push the Endless Lies
out that's what I'm saying we don't
expect everything to be perfect we don't
expect everything to be all truthful all
the time or anything else but right now
the left and the corporate media and all
of it runs on nothing other than live
and a whole bunch of us can see that and
that's why more people are waking up in
red pilling and everything else right I
get the messages from you guys every day
on that but then on the other side if
this is what Trump's going to do
rewriting history and DeSantis is evil
and Florida is evil and they're not
knowing what the bills are that he's
putting forward and being confused about
where classified documents were with his
personal stuff and all the stuff like
the lying the just the endless lying has
to stop but if you disagree with me on
that particularly on the Trump side I
want to hear from you I want to hear why
you think endless lying in the quest for
power is okay like do the ends justify
the means I don't think so I don't think
so but I know some people do
let's just do two more things here a
little bit on the importance of telling
the truth and who better than Jordan
Peterson
the consequences of not saying what was
true is like whatever hell you might
fall into by opening your mouth when you
have something to say that isn't popular
it's nothing like the hell that you're
going to envelop yourself in if you lose
control of your own tongue and mind and
I like I said in my clinical practice I
never saw anyone get away with anything
even once and so all you have in a
situation like that is what is the truth
now you know of course you only have
your approximations to the truth but
that's better than nothing you need to
be afraid of the right thing and you
should be afraid of contaminating your
soul with deceit that's what you should
be afraid of that will definitely do you
in and I know exactly how what happens
is
you know garbage in garbage out the old
programmers saying goes and so you'll
fill your head with nonsense and no one
will call you on it except you but you
can still that voice if you try hard
enough you just wait until you get in
real trouble
you can't get away with it one way or
another right like the endless lying or
the not saying what you know to be true
because you think you can skirt around
it or you'll Escape or just you'll take
the easy way out
um that's why I'm curious for those of
you that are supporting Trump through
all of the lies and by the way
please if Ron DeSantis or the campaign
just starts relentlessly lying about
everything Trump Biden Florida blah blah
if I don't call it out call Nia right
like that's the best we can do that's
the best we can do but are you okay with
the destruction of Truth in the quest
for power that would be my question for
Donald Trump right now I just want to
play one other uh short video this is
Carl Sagan I've mentioned Carl Sagan a
bunch of times on the show I think we've
shown one or two clips of him over the
years he was the incredible astronomer
and science Communicator professor at
Cornell University he wrote the book
Cosmos was really his most ubiquitous
book that then became the incredible
science series that was on American
television I think late 70s early 80s
what many of you might know him from was
the incredible movie it's one of my top
three favorite movies of all time is the
only work of fiction was the movie
contact with Jody Foster and Matthew
McConaughey just an absolutely
absolutely wonderful movie if you
haven't seen it actually at the
beginning of covid we were doing movie
Nights with the locals community and we
all watched that one together and then
talked about it after uh anyway here he
is uh he's long since passed but here he
is talking about why we should not
suppress ideas and what the path to
knowledge really is all about
suppression of uncomfortable ideas may
be common in religion or in politics but
it is not the path to knowledge and
there's no place for it in the Endeavor
of science
all right so the path to knowledge I get
it politicians lie
I get it people from the media lie but
as we are seeing so many lies
disintegrate in front of our eyes right
like the long list of Lies Donald Trump
very fine people on both sides Brett
Kavanaugh is a serial rapist Russia
collusion this that the other thing well
then maybe it's incumbent on us to try
to get out of this with something that's
true and I think that that's where Trump
is sort of caught right now okay they're
all liars but the way to get out of
their lying Abyss is not through lies
it's through truth that's how you'll
build something that'll get us out of
the quicksand
I think that's what we got to do
and as I always say I don't think I'm
the only one rumble.com Ruben report if
you have not subscribed already by the
way I'm very proud to say I think I
announced it on the show yesterday that
Robert F Kennedy Jr has officially
launched on Rumble we are the official
home for free speech online we've got a
post game show for you guys at
reubenreport.locals.com starting in 30
seconds and we leave you with the
hyena-like laughter of Vice President
Kamala Harris
amen well I want to thank on that note
amen you can get an amen even though it
is not Sunday thank God I appreciate
that I like your neighbor tell your
neighbor
I want to thank the honor
[Music]